الشعور بانك ثانوي قطعه غيار قد تستخدم
عند حدوث كارثه هكذا قضى الامير هاري
حياته سجين احساس بالظلم خلف السوار
القصور العاليه في لندن حتى حرره الحب
وقرر ان يتحكمه وبسرد حكايته في مذكرات
حملت عنوان سبير او الاحتياطي صدرت رسميا
اليوم في الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
كشفت المذكره تفاصيل محرجه عن الامير هاري
وعائلته الملكيه ولم يسلم منها حتى الجيش
البريطاني ومع تسرب مقاطع من الكتاب غمرت
الانتقادات اللاذعه الاميره وزوجته
التي قال انها غير مسؤوله عن قراره
بمواجهه العالم
[موسيقى]
صدوق وذوقه ساسكس اختار الولايات المتحده
ملجا بعد هروبهما من بلد مثقال بارثه
الاستعمار والعنصريه المنهجه بحسب هاري
وقالت ماجن في مناسبات عده انها لم تعامل
قبل ذهابها الى لندن كامراه سوداء ما اوحى
بان العنصريه غريبه عن المجتمع الامريكي
وهو يطراء يستدعي رد الجميل ومن اسباب
التعاطف ايضا ان الامريكيين ينظرون الى
هاري وماجن كلثوريين يسعيان الى مناهضه
غياب العداله المؤسساتيه ولزوجين منظمه
غير ربحيه هدفها استثمار التعاطف لاحداث
التغيير في المجتمعات وقد كسب الامير
وزوجته تعاطفا اكبر من خلال الحديث علانيه
عن معاناتهما
[موسيقى]
قصه هاري مع الاعلام الامريكي ليست ورديه
تماما فقد وبخته مقالات نشرت في صحف
امريكيه على تصريحاته الفضائيه عن العائله
الملكيه
وحذرته من مستقبل حافل بندم كثير لكنه لا
يريد بحسب قوله سواء اظهار الحقيقه
لكن الحقيقه اكثر تعقيدا مما نعتقد
والاشخاص الاخرين الذين يسكنون قصصنا
لديهم حقائقهم ايضا الامير ويليام شقيقه
هاري لديه وجهه نظر قد لا نعرف عنها من
ولي العهد الصامت ابدا لصباح العربيه هند
ابراهيم واشنطن